[Music]
one day the universe will die but why
and how and will the universe be dead
forever
and how do we know that first of all the
universe is expanding and not only that
the rate of its expansion is
accelerating the reason dark energy dark
energy is a strange phenomenon that
scientists believe permeates the
universe until 1998 we thought that the
universe must work a bit like a book
that you throw into the sky the ball
moves up but at some point it has to
come down again but of the expansion of
the universe is actually speeding up
that's like throwing a ball up and
watching it fly away faster and faster
and faster where is this acceleration
coming from well we don't know but we
call it dark energy
Einstein thought of it first and then
decided it was stupid
now astrophysicists have decided it is
plausible trouble is this is all very
theoretical and we don't actually know
what the properties of dark energy are
but there are various theories and they
lead us to three scenarios for the end
of the universe
[Music]
one the big rip since its birth the
universe has been expanding for unknown
reasons new space is created everywhere
equally the space between galaxies
expands so they move apart the space
inside galaxies also expands but here
gravity is strong enough to keep them
together in the big rip scenario the
expansion accelerates up to a point
where space expands so fast
the gravity can't compensate for this
effect anymore the result is a big rip
at first only large structures like
galaxies are torn apart since space
between the single objects expands very
fast
next big bodies like black holes of
stars and planets die their gravity
isn't strong enough to keep them
together so they dissolve into their
components in the end space would expand
faster than the speed of light atoms
would now be affected than they would
just disband once space is expanding
faster than light no particle to need of
us can interact with any other particle
anymore the universe would dissolve into
countless lowly particles that won't be
able to touch anything else in a strange
timeless universe hmm and you thought
you felt lonely
- heat death or a big freeze in a
nutshell the difference between the big
rip and heat death is that in a heat
death scenario matter stays intact and
is converted over an incredibly long but
finite period of time into radiation
while the universe expands forever but
how does this work let's talk about
entropy every system tends towards the
state of highest entropy like when we
have a latin macchiato initially it has
different regions but over time they
will cool down and disintegrate until
it's uniform and this also applies to
the universe so while the universe gets
bigger and bigger matter slowly decays
and spreads out at some point after lots
of generations of stars all the gas
clouds necessary to form stars will be
exhausted so the universe will turn dark
the remaining sons will die black holes
will slowly degenerate and evaporate
over trillions of years due to what's
known as Hawking radiation when this
process is complete only a dilute gas of
photons and Nanak particles remains
until even this decays all activity in
the universe ceases at this point
entropy is at its maximum and the
universe is dead forever
unless theoretically it might be
possible for - for an incredibly long
amount of time there might be a
spontaneous entropy decrease as a result
of something called quantum tunneling
leading to a new Big Bang 3 Big Crunch
and Big Bounce this is the most
uplifting scenario if there is less dark
energy than we think or it decreases
over time gravity will be the dominating
force in the universe one day in a few
trillion years the rate of expansion of
the universe will slow down and stop
after that it reverses galaxies will
race at each other merging as the
universe becomes smaller and smaller
since the smaller universe also means a
hotter universe temperatures rise
everywhere all at once
100,000 years before the Big Crunch
background radiation would be hotter
than the surfaces of most stars which
means that they would be cooked from the
outside minutes before the Big Crunch
happens atom caused a ripped apart
before supermassive black holes too far
everything finally all black holes would
merge into a supermassive mega black
hole that contains the entire mass of
the universe and in the last moment
before the Big Crunch it would devour
the universe including itself the Big
Bounce theory states that this has
happened a lot of times and that the
universe goes through an infinite cycle
of expansion and contraction well
wouldn't that be nice so what will
actually happen to the universe in the
end at the moment heat death seemed the
most likely but we it cuts cos out hope
that this dead forever stuff is wrong
and the universe will start over and
over again
we don't know for sure either way so
let's just assume the most uplifting
theory is true
by the way we have a Twitter account
[Music]